you know um just because you want to
walk away from the craziness that's
going on it doesn't protect your kids
from it it doesn't protect the schools
from it unless you become literally
Amish
um so now I'm in the airport this lady's
like screaming on the floor and we go to
rebook the flight she's like yelling at
the at the flight attendant I swear I
looked at her and I was like this is
your own fault because she was she was
literally trying to blame she was trying
to blame the flight attendants because
the plane they closed the doors like
five minutes before the flight opened or
whatever and she got there like right as
the flight is supposed to take off and
I'm thinking this lady's freaking nuts
it's your own fault and get their you
know what I mean like you know I missed
it too I'm not gonna I'm not gonna cry